the brothers foundation in Toronto has
done a lot of work on this one for the
question regarding are you familiar with
the work and the theories of Buckminster
Fuller in terms of world game you know
it's been so long since I read
Buckminster Fuller that I think I'd
better say now yeah yeah well he was
very admired in the day I there are a
lot of things I should reread that's
probably one of them I thank you for
speaking it's an honor to be in your
presence how much of trade do you think
can be balanced at what countries are
more reliable for a more balanced
economy in those impoverished nations
there's a South Korean economist called
ha-joon Chang who teaches at Cambridge
University in the UK and he's done a lot
of work suggesting that the only way
nations prosper is to begin by being
protectionist and the Korean model has
been is very interesting in that regard
because Korea in post-war Korea which is
now a developed country started out with
a tremendous protectionist dynamic I
don't I'm not you know he's very sure
that he has the answers I'm somebody who
generally you know thinks if I think I
have all the answers it means I must not
have asked the right questions but
there's certainly evidence that
nineteenth-century America was
protectionist that South Korea after the
end of the Korean War was protectionist
and at least that the idea that free
markets and the China I mean what's the
greatest single example of reduction in
poverty in the world today it's China
China is a completely protectionist
economy it's the Chinese economy is a
rigged game and yet the prosperity of
now about three
million Chinese is you know undeniable
indeed if you take optimistic statistics
about development about poverty and you
strip out the Chinese contribution to it
you get much more dismal figures you
know people tell you about progress in
aggregate but again if you if you you
know if progress is X and China is y X
minus y is not a good result may not
happen you look at India it you know
maybe mr. Modi and the new government
will succeed in in making prosperity the
protectionism in India in the so called
license raj in the in the nubian times
was not successful in many important
ways but we'll see I mean I don't think
there's one formula but I do think that
trusting I think things have to come
from inside places I mean if I had my
way there's this pipe dream it'll never
happen
you know NGOs in the global north would
stop being operational and start just
being funders I think it's about time
you know the Imperial penumbral was was
ended even though a lot of these NGOs do
extremely good work and in emergencies
in particular truly admirable work but
in the end you know societies don't
change from the better from the outside
in my view that was the Imperial fantasy
that you know the British were going to
abolish sati and in
and you know even the war in Afghanistan
that the george w bush's woman tony
blair's war in afghanistan was partly
justified because it would empower
indian afghan women right I don't think
that's how enduring change sustainable
change happens even if you grant that
that was the intention rather than a
kind of ex post facto justification
which is it's what I believe yes ma'am
this opposition by some countries
particularly in Europe to GMOs have any
factor in this globally I don't think so
I think that I mean I don't have a
strong opinion about GMOs i I don't feel
I have this sign I mean I actually there
was a Polish poet called Miss lavage in
Moscow who is a great heroine of mine
and she toward the very end of her lash
won the Nobel prizes in the nine she
said toward the end of her life that I
don't know had become her favorite
sentence and I'm rather tempted to you
know take refuge in that at this moment
but certainly I was absolutely convinced
as I wrote this book that I just didn't
have the science to have a right to an
opinion about GMOs but as a political
analyst if China India in part Brazil in
toto Argentina the United States Canada
all accept GMOs what the Europeans do is
frankly a very little consequence in my
view
any others I think the lady in the front
um my question is do we have enough
production I mean the the food
production for everybody on the earth if
we do then it's not I think it's a
distribution people who are hungry right
now because they don't have money to buy
food it's not not enough food on earth
that's certainly true now the lady said
that you know the problem was partly
distribution and partly access and in
that not absolute production and I
certainly think and I make this point in
the book in probably should have made it
in the talk but you can't unless you
prepare a speech and when I was a
student
people who lectured me from reading
things bored me so completely that once
people started asking me to talk in
public I decided I would should wing it
for better or worse one of these days
I'll get up in a situation like this
open my mouth and absolutely nothing
will come out but so far so good it's a
guy set a 50th story dropping down to
the ground the the lays question or
comment is absolutely borne out by the
facts a Martius sin the great Indian
economist what's his what what did he
come I mean he has many roles he's a
political philosopher he saw his nemesis
there other things yes but as an
economist an economic historian what he
showed was that in the great Bengal
famine of 1943 that there was enough
food there were strained resources
because the British Empire was taking
some of the food stocks and supply away
from bingo and giving it to the troops
but even then it wasn't that there was
no food it was that poor people couldn't
afford the prices of the food and that's
so he Sen has always argued that the
problem of
is indeed a problem of access and what
he calls entitlement and I think that's
right as of now is there enough food to
feed everybody on the planet yes
absolutely
now I don't want to go too far down this
road because remember Malthus only has
to be right once he can be wrong decade
in and decade out but he only has to be
right once in a particular region he's
not gonna be right globally the problem
is again coming partly back to global
warming and partly back I mean I called
this book food justice and money for a
reason because I do think the
fundamental problem of hunger is a lack
of justice rather than a lack of
production and my big criticism of the
UN's view and a business driven
development is that it's you see it's
largely market driven and productivist
but there is a fly in that anointment
which is that lets say country x
produces a huge surplus are they really
going is country X going to make it
available to poor people who can't
afford to pay for it we're out of the
world market in a certain sense what are
they going to exported to countries with
rising middle classes China is a good
example of that or indeed are they gonna
use food staples that could feed hungry
people for meat production I mean
remember that what we you know a lot of
the the certainly of the you know the
four staple grains are used to feed you
know pigs and chickens and cattle and
particularly cattle and that that's a
very inefficient way of providing
for people because you know it's cattle
wheat you know the count the the the
energy in is much larger than the energy
meat provides but these are cultural
questions I mean you're not going to
talk some newly prosperous person in
Shanghai I've tried I mean I've had
these conversations I spent a great deal
of time when I was researching this book
at both China and India you know you go
to somebody and they say you know I like
to eat made it you know it's my culture
and now there's more of it and that's
great um so I don't know how you make
access possible except through more
justice and less inequality and those
are political issues that's the great
problem with the scientific /
technological account is its it's
finally productivist and that's not the
way we're gonna get out of this yes
thank you for coming so you talked a lot
about returning the power to the state
and the global south and with all the
political unrest going around in the
south and also in the Middle East areas
that are impoverished how would you
recommend that NGOs perhaps even if they
were to stop organizing and start
funding rather instead how are these
governments going to become stable
enough to help in poverty within their
regions well I mean the first thing I
would say is that it's it's not for us
to decide these things you know that
that it's not up to doctor what is the
legitimacy of the Ford Foundation in
deciding what the government of chod
should be I mean I'm sorry but I mean
there I have a lot of friends at the
Ford Foundation and they've done a lot
of good work but in the end countries
I'll give you a counterfactual maybe
it's a better way to
we think it's perfectly normal to say to
have NGOs going around in places where
you know government is dysfunctional
let's use a polite term and it seems
perfectly normal that I don't know the
new york-based International Rescue
Committee goes to Malawi or it goes to
Burma
or it goes wherever to to things just
ask yourself what people in this country
maybe not you but what most people in
this country would have thought if
during Katrina the Venezuelan government
had sent aid teams and yet there was no
difference
I mean Katrina was as royally botched as
you know any emergency in modern memory
the same description you gave of these
governments in the global south could
have been given of all the actors from
George Bush's FEMA administrator's name
I fortunately brown brown Oh
I mean in the end absent world
government nations have to work it out
history you know history doesn't go at
the same speed everywhere if I could
show you books written by British
imperial travelers about Singapore in
1900 saying that the climate and the
Confucian culture made it absolutely
impossible that these people could
amount to anything
you know it's by many measures the most
prosperous and in pure you know health
outcomes educational levels etc
successful countries in the world things
change but I don't think the Imperial
method is going is sustainable anyway I
mean some things have to be countries
have to go through things
I mean imagine here's another
counterfactual for you imagine that in
1861 when the American Civil War was
about to begin
that the Martians had landed and said we
don't want you to fight this war war is
an uncivilized business you must heed us
they theirs first of all societies have
to work out you don't want it to be
worked out by war but sometimes I'm not
a pacifist I think sometimes there is a
place for war and you know I think that
these countries have to go through the
things they're going through you can
help but you know the biggest help would
not be NGOs it would be making
corporations pay for countries that
taxes their own would a lot be stolen
sure but at some point it's not
unreasonable to believe that things
might change and that's that's not
optimism but it's not pessimism either
I think this better be the last one more
and we're done
[Music]
[Music]
like why don't we one day electrical
system so that when one part of the
world needs it
[Music]
efficiency is just
distribution
well tell that to someone who's in a
boat risking their neck trying to get
from Libya to Lampa duza I mean yeah it
doesn't that doesn't make me want to
read him again I have to tell you I mean
that's just to me that's just playing
with words so I think unless someone has
are absolutely pressing thing out thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
book TV is on Instagram follow us for
publishing news schedule updates and
behind the scenes pictures and videos
instagram.com slash book underscore TV
University of Wisconsin professor
Jennifer Ratner Rosen Hagen who is
Frederick Nietzsche Frederick Nietzsche
was a German 19th century German
philosopher who wrote many many many
many books a philosophy in all sorts of
different forms and all of them said
some aphoristic some essay istic some
longer form critiques and all of them
had something to do with the challenge
of universal truth so he he he took as
his enemy the notion of universal truth
and pretty much all of his work has
something to do with his effort to tear
it down excavate it look at the history
of that idea and to show that anything
that we take to be our universals like
Oh God
are human creations but they're not
rooted in nature or necessity they're
not mirrors of reality he wrote at one
time God is dead and he wrote that God
is dead and this make first makes its
appearance in his gay science and in it
the gay science in it it's a an aphorism
and it's called the madman and so the
Afro ISM is he's playing with this this
idea that a madman runs into the to the
town square and says god is dead god is
dead we have killed him you and I and
everybody says oh he's crazy oh he's
crazy
and he realizes oh my time has not come
yet and so there he's announcing what
what's gonna be basically his
intellectual project for the rest of his
his writing life before he goes insane
and that is the notion that god is dead
what troubled nietzsche was that in over
the course of 19th century as in
particular germans became more modern
and more secular but they continued to
go to church and pray to a god that they
didn't really believe in anymore in
other words he thought that modern
thought modern science the forces of
modernity were undermining the basis of
religion and yet he said people still
held held onto it
they still clutched
to it because they were too terrified to
live without it and this he found really
despicable and that's that's that's what
he tries to work out in his philosophy
where did he teach how did he come about
was he well known at this time
Nietzsche well we have to sort of
separate the myth from the the from the
reality which is that Nietzsche did have
moments of modest Fame actually his
first book the birth of tragedy had a
pretty big reception but then he did
fade into obscurity he was a philosopher
in Basel so a professor of language
history of language the genealogy of
language but the academic life wasn't
for him he he suffered from a lot of
physical ailments ailments pardon me
so I mean historians and philosophers
debate why did he why did he have such a
tough time in the Academy although some
of us in the Academy nowadays don't
wonder that much but anyway Nietzsche
taught for ten years in Basel with some
success but due to reasons that we can
only sort of imperfectly suss out was it
his health was it what he said which is
that he needed to break free
Nietzsche breaks free lives on a pension
the rest of his life and gets to inhabit
the image of the free thinker that he so
exalts and worships in his own
philosophy so but Nietzsche didn't have
a huge readership for for most of his
productive life and I say productive
life because in 1889 he has a nervous
collapse and spends the last 11 years of
his life in a very declining state I
mean and ends up in a totally vegetative
state
and dies in 1900 he's discovered so how
does nature become Nietzsche he's
discovered precisely in those months
when his health is declining shortly
before this mental collapse so one of
the
irony's of friedrich nietzsche's life
and the posthumous life of his ideas is
that it's in the moment when his when
intellectually and mentally you know
there's a closing of accounts for him
that's the moment when the floodgates
open and he becomes the superstar that
he is today who discovered him
how was he he was discovered this is a
little tricky because there's always a
quest for a priority people were reading
Nietzsche but were those people being
read but I think it's fair to say that
the the Danish critic George Brandis who
himself had a big audience in the late
19th century he is credited with
discovering each and I think that's a
fair assessment that he brings the most
famed to Nietzsche and they actually do
have a brief correspondence in that last
year just as madness is closing in on
Nietzsche and Nietzsche things finally
finally someone recognizes my genius and
then lo and behold he has mental
collapse and turan and that's pretty
much the end of his productive life
so Brandes is credited largely with kind
of getting the word out in northern
european circles that that Nietzsche's
Nietzsche's one to watch and that's when
each his reputation boom really takes
off who followed him who liked his work
what kind of people what kind of
everybody there everybody
atheists religionists the left the right
women men black whites old people young
people so Nietzsche that's not immediate
because he needs to be translated yeah
Nietzsche is not translated in earnest
until the late into the 1896 1897 is the
first round of translations then there's
another major effort of translations
that happen in the early 20th century of
course in the late 19th century in early
20th century a lot of educated Americans
could read German
so people were reading him you know in
the original but it really did require
the translations for him to take off
Henry who had eight why am i calling him
Henry
HL Mencken he was in the coat by Henry
HL Mencken
has a lot to do with Nietzsche's
superstardom no it's not to say that
there weren't other folks who were
reading Nietzsche and popularizing
Nietzsche in the United States before
mingkun but Menken is the one who writes
the first full-length monograph on
Nietzsche in 1908 and that's where we
get a kind of full-on synopsis about
Nietzsche's life his travails his
struggles with Christianity his
struggles with health we get a little
bit about each of sexuality
it wouldn't be Minkin if there wasn't a
little something racy thrown in and then
we get Nietzsche's ideas boom and this
book sold widely and sold well and it
helped do two things it helped really
establish in each's reputation in
America but it did something else which
is of course it helped men can become
Menken so if somebody says I love
friedrich nietzsche
i agree with him what are they saying to
you professor if they're just saying
that not much because someone i'm going
to use the example of chess something
atheists and bible-thumping christians
could both make that claim about
Nietzsche and that's what's so startling
about his perception is that he doesn't
track right or left
he doesn't track religious or secular he
tracks or rather he tracks all over our
intellectual spectrum so just the
statement I love Nietzsche doesn't tell
me much of anything other than that's an
utterly conventional experience a - you
know find Nietzsche so powerful in fact
I think what's so so interesting is how
many people will say and have said over
the course of the late 19th 20th century
of course until our own time how they
felt when they read Nietzsche he was
speaking to them personally so one of
the things I argue in the book is that
Nietzsche becomes a superstar public
philosopher by way of private longings
and private fears so
you have a strange you have a disturbed
look on your face who wouldn't like
Friedrich Nietzsche them oh there are
plenty of people who don't like
Friedrich who don't like Friedrich
Nietzsche and there were things not to
like
he didn't say very nice things about
democracy
he didn't say very nice things about
women he didn't say very nice things
about equality and so if these are
things that matter to you you're gonna
take issue with him so let me give you a
concrete example of what's what's to
like and what's not to like about
Nietzsche and oh gosh I can take any
anyone but I'll take one of the more
spectacular examples and that is the
Leopold and Loeb trial of 1924 so
Leopold and Loeb are two University of
Chicago students who think that they are
the uber mentioned that they are what
Nietzsche had in mind when he wrote
about the even mention and they wanted
to prove it to themselves just beyond
the ubermensch is the the Superman it
gets translated as the Superman in fact
the Superman as in Superman comic which
we tend to think of as you know
Americana has its roots in Nietzsche's
ubermensch in fact the two men the two
boys are men who come up with Superman
were readers of Nietzsche so that's just
a little and there's many cases like
that I mean even I think the fact that
we have the word uber you know but uber
I think comes into our language in the
way that it does by way of deliver much
anyway but that we're talking about an
example where we have two views that say
they have the right Nietzsche and that
is Leopold and Loeb they read Nietzsche
they think that he's the they're the
Superman he had in mind and so they want
to prove it to themselves and so they
kill they kidnap and kill a
fourteen-year-old boy Bobby Franks and
the south side of Chicago they get
caught it turns out that they weren't so
uber as they thought Clarence Darrow the
famed trial attorney becomes their
defense lawyer and he's also a reader of
Nietzsche but he's not a murderer
in fact he's quite sure that that's not
what Nietzsche had in mind and so the
interesting thing about the whole
Leopold and Loeb trial which is trying
to save these boys from these young men
from being killed themselves is how
Darrow had to not make to both say the
reason why they did this is because
Nietzsche is toxic and a dangerous
thinker and they misunderstood him and
yet Nietzsche is an important thinker
that we need in modern life but we need
to handle him with care so so it's I'm
just something like that the Leopold and
Loeb trial you see those sorts of
negotiations where in Nietzsche is both
you know public enemy number one as we
see with with a murder but we also see
with a Clarence Darrow saying no
Nietzsche is the thinker that we
Americans need in order to embrace
modern life political movements that
have co-opted Nietzsche oh so many I
think the one that I mean really the the
whole 20th century is a story of
coaptation I think the one that
surprises my readers the most or at
least when I get letters from readers or
I get or come into contact with readers
its Nietzsche the hidden Nietzschean
origins of black power
so Huey P Newton was a reader of
Friedrich Nietzsche and in Nietzsche he
discovered he discovered a lot of things
in Nietzsche but what he understood from
Nietzsche is he needed me to tell him
that the things that your culture tell
you are true and are universal it's in
fact made up or it's a it's a product of
history it's a product of chance it's
somewhat arbitrary but it's not true and
so don't take the voice of a racist
culture as the voice of your own inner
conscience yeah and this is what Sochi
for Huey P Newton this is what Nietzsche
did for African Americans
is to help them hear that they no longer
had to pray to the white man's God they
no longer had to make themselves
prostrate to a religion and in his view
that made them supplicants and that they
shouldn't take this morality which tries
to discipline them and keep them down as
something universal as something
timeless and so Huey P Newton is is
really intellectually if you will
cutting his teeth on Nietzsche as he and
Bobby Seale are coming together and
formulating the basis of black power
World War two no the the reason why I
say is there are I don't know of any
other philosopher in history
that's blamed for two world wars but
Nietzsche was so you can't just quickly
World War two I actually think is the
more interesting story here because all
the ways in which each has reputation is
just so terribly damaged but just
quickly if I'm a World War one Nietzsche
when World War one breaks out and this
is so shocking to American observers it
starts to come out
you know it's Nietzsche its Nietzsche
its nature rumors of German ministers
preaching Nietzsche from their pulpits
it wasn't hard to listen and hear traces
of Nietzsche and philosophy behind the
blood and iron imperialism of World War
Germany during World War one and so
Nietzsche is yoked to World War one and
has a very hard time well those who want
to try to save his reputation and say
this wasn't what he intended this is
just the misuse of Nietzsche had a
really hard hard time afterwards then of
course Leopold and Loeb don't do much
for his reputation and then with the
rise of Hitler not not Mussolini
initially who was a reader of Nietzsche
and an enthusiast of Nietzsche Hitler
the rise of Hitler in particular was the
more I think those sort of the more
terrifying development so over the
course of the 1930s
see the specter of Nazism and then later
as Americans started to see Mussolini as
a greater threat than they initially had
it was not hard to find Nietzschean
traces behind Nazi philosophy and
Mussolini's fascism and so long behold
Nietzsche
you know yet again is seen as the the
author and visionary of what would
become world war two
of course nature wrote up things that
were not so hard to turn into to make
him implicated he wrote of the rise of
the blond beast so which people thought
took to be his celebration of the Aryan
race his sister actually was a proto
Nazi and in her her closing years she
welcomes Hitler to the Nietzsche archive
so there's a there's a linkage to Hitler
and some very unfortunate pictures of
Hitler and Elizabeth Forrester Nietzsche
with the Nietzsche bust at the nature
archive so in the American imagination
let Nietzsche really gets linked to
World War two and the entire Nazi
ideology that not here we have the
Germans who didn't just want an uber
mensch
but they wanted an uber race and we know
the language of unter mention the
subhuman people which was all throughout
Germany during during World War two
Nietzsche was just implicated in all of
this what's his reputation today in hood
who's the anti Nietzsche philosopher
whose ins is there such a thing oh
there's plenty yeah but I don't think
there is interesting sure I mean George
Santayana is not a thinker that we talk
about much today though we should
because he was a towering intellectual a
towering philosopher and poet and
novelist in the early twentieth century
he thought Nietzsche was everything that
was wrong with what he called the German
mind that hypertrophied self
yeah the hyper grande ice
he thought that that German the German
what he called the German mind or the
German temperament and he traces this
back to content up through Hegel and the
Nietzsche becomes the great exemplar is
an intellectual or mind that just didn't
couldn't deal with limits so we actually
referred to Nietzsche's amateurish and
adolescent so he is pretty dismissive of
Nietzsche and that's an example of a
thinker who I think is a very robust
thinker and a careful thinker
there are plenty there are plenty others
I actually think an interesting case
here is an example the example of Alan
bloom who in the reception of his famous
book the closing of the American mind
you know a blockbuster book Alan bloom
says you know what's the wrong with
higher education it's killing the souls
of our children they're getting all this
pluralism they're getting all this
multiculturalism but what they're not
getting is great ideas and they're not
getting the the challenges of those
great ideas so it's how that how higher
education is impoverishing our nature
our but the the souls of our of our
children and nietzsche is right there
all along he even talks about the
Nietzschean ization of american
intellectual life and according to bloom
he thinks that so much of what is wrong
in late night late twentieth-century
intellectual life is that intellectuals
are reading their Nietzsche and kind of
like what George Santayana says they're
tired of universal truth they're tired
of power they're of someone else's power
they're tired of Authority and so he he
says that all that the counterculture of
the 1960s
is nursed on Miche and I'm anti
authoritarianism and he said this is
it's one thing to have these kinds of
protests in the streets it's another
thing to bring them into the Academy and
make such a ruckus so he's very critical
of the uses of Nietzsche so I hit the
pause button here if you read how
everyone's talking about Alan blooms
book and they were talking and they were
talking
we're talking because as you know it was
a major major major blockbuster people
picked up on a ha you know
Nietzsche uh Alan bloom blames Nietzsche
you know it's the Nietzschean ization of
our American intellectual life blah blah
blah blah blah so you would think that
Alan bloom you know had a problem with
Nietzsche he didn't he thought Nietzsche
was a genius he loved me Chia
he wrote beautifully about Nietzsche he
wrote longingly about Nietzsche he
thought Nietzsche was a genius and his
problem was that he thought he was in a
culture of intellectual pygmies who
could not appreciate the genius of
Nietzsche so and so what he's actually
doing in the closing of the American
mind which i think is such an
interesting move he's not really blaming
Nietzsche for the impoverishment of
American intellectual life yeah the sort
of anti-authoritarianism that he finds
so despicable he's blaming what he says
is readers who just aren't up to the
task
of truly understanding this great genius
so again that's not someone who's
critical of Nietzsche per se although he
has a reputation for having you know
pinned all the failures of late 20th
century American intellectual life on
Nietzsche quite the opposite what he's
trying to do is keep his own private
Nietzsche a Nietzsche in his own image
against what he sees as the slavish
inadequate impoverished American
intellectual life that just can't handle
these powerful ideas Jennifer Ratner
Rosen Hagen you've written a biography
of Friedrich Nietzsche are you a fan if
I may I would say I that I wouldn't
people call it a biography of Friedrich
Nietzsche but it's actually a biography
of his ideas as they come to life in
America so one of the things I say in
the book is that it's not this is not
actually a book about Nietzsche
in fact some readers have been
disappointed of course he crops up quite
a bit but the book is not about
Nietzsche I'm an American historian I'm
an American intellectual and cultural
historian my interest is the history of
Americans
culture over 19th and 20th century what
I discovered is you can't when you get
to the late 19th century in the twenty
through the 20th century you can't talk
about American intellectual life without
talking about Nietzsche's presence his
curious presence really and his
influence SUNY was just a little modest
correction here it's not about Nietzsche
it's about us so every reading of
Nietzsche I'm not listening whether HL
Mencken or Clarence Darrow or Walter
Kaufmann who become so important to
redeem in each after World War two or
Shoei P Newton or Alan bloom are getting
him right or wrong I don't think that's
the interesting question for a historian
to ask what I'm trying to do is listen
in to what they have to say about
Nietzsche to listen to see what that
tells us about American intellectual
life in that particular moment so the
book is actually not about Nietzsche
it's about us it's about our
intellectual life and it's about our
coming to coming to our own ideas about
truth about democracy about Christianity
about God by way of Nietzsche
but I'm dodging the question has he in
your view been a positive influence in
American political and cultural life uh
you know what that's incredible I've
never been asked that question I think
he's a necessary influence because I
think he's right I mean I think there's
a lot of Duncan what he says there's a
lot of grandstanding in my chisme but
you clear away some of that gunk and the
the the ideas I think are ideas that we
had to him had to come to terms with
which is again to just repeat what I
said earlier the notion that so much of
what we take to be universally true
whether it be God whether it be
democracy whether it would be whatever
it is
Nietzsche gave us a way of looking at
those ideas those truth claims to see
their origins and their genealogy and
Nietzsche helped Americans to see that
so many truth claims
are not rooted in reality they're rooted
and power they're rooted in needs
they're rooted in fear they're rooted
and longing but they're not necessarily
rooted in truth and I think this is this
is necessary
I mean if for any culture truthfully but
especially American culture because we
have from the start been a very
pluralistic culture of many languages of
many religions of many ethnicities of
different races and so part of what it
means to be American right from our
earliest years here is contested truths
is a pluralistic sensibility is a land
of many religions and many beliefs and
we haven't we never did a good job of
negotiating we're gonna do it that great
a job of negotiating this prior to
Nietzsche but Nietzsche becomes his
ideas become important as we negotiate
this moving forward so an answer to your
question do you I think is a positive
force yeah and he's also been a negative
force although he had nothing to do with
it because he was long dead but and his
ideas have been read in all sorts of
curious ways but I think as I as I said
I think he was a necessary force and in
that regard salutary force because he
helped Americans to confront fundamental
problems that we've had which is
problems of living in a pluralistic
society and doing so in a humane way and
and and and for that I think well here
I'll just because a historian many
people were grateful in the 20th century
that they had Nietzsche to think with
about these issues University of
Wisconsin professor Jennifer Ratner
Rosen Hagin teaches history here at the
University
here's her book American Nietzsche a
history of an icon and his ideas you're
watching book TV and she's been to
you're watching book TV on c-span 2 with
top nonfiction books and authors every
weekend book TV television for serious
readers
News reports a US Supreme Court Justice
Antonin Scalia was found dead earlier
today at a West Texas ranch reports say
he was a guest at a resort in the Big
Bend region
Justice Scalia arrived at the ranch on
Friday and attended a private party with
about 40 people when he did not appear
for breakfast a person associated with
the ranch went to his room and found a
body the US Marshals Service the
presidio County Sheriff and the FBI are
involved in the investigation a federal
official who asked not to be named told
one newspaper there was no evidence of
foul play and it appeared that Scalia
died of natural causes Scalia the
longest serving justice on the court was
nominated in 1986 by President Ronald
Reagan Justice Antonin Scalia was 79
he spoke with book TV in 2008 about his
book making your case
what what most annoys me yes sir I think
any judge any appellate judge he'll
probably tell you it's a council's
evasion of questions trying to avoid
giving a straight and simple answer
instead of saying yes or no they'll go
into a long explanation you've got a
whole chapter in your book making your
case about brevity yes brevity is the
soul of wit never heard never heard
judges complained that an argument was
too short as an oral argument in the
court ever changed your mind about a
case I think you know that that's a
common question most people seem to be
under the impression that you know the
oral arguments just a dog-and-pony show
what I'm telling you is is what almost
all appellate judges will tell you it
doesn't change your mind that often but
it frequently makes up your mind because
though many of the cases are very close
and you go in on the knife's edge
persuasive counsel and can really make
the difference so it's you know it's
well worth doing right who should read
this book Oh anybody argue in front of
me so because it'll not only help him
it'll help me his argument will be
shorter he'll answer my questions I'll
be able to understand the case a lot
better what have you learned on this
book tour about book touring and what do
you think about the dog-and-pony show
that sometimes comes with it
no I you know I'm gonna be here wider
maybe an hour and a half or so end of
the day I'm not worth much at the day
anyway have you been touring quite a bit
have you gone out throughout the country
I've I've done a book signing when I am
somewhere for some other reason giving a
lecture at a university speaking to an
organization something like that I'll do
the book tour a book signing I think
it's only a couple of times that I've
really scheduled a book signing there's
there's nothing personal in this book
like justice Thomas's book now I have a
pretty dull biography I couldn't if it
wouldn't be worth reading Justice
Antonin Scalia with his co-author Brian
Garner who is Brian Garland's not here
Brian is a more prominent author than I
am by a good deal he's the editor of
Black's Law Dictionary he has a number
of books on how to write briefs
how to how to make oral argument how to
use the words of the law properly as a
dictionary on American modern American
legal usage so he's a very prominent
fellow if he were here you should be
interviewing Justice Antonin Scalia is
also an author thank you sir thank you
book TV continues now with Barry Lazar
on afterwards the criminologist tracked
violent crime in the United States from
the 1960s to today many of this year's
presidential candidates have written
books to introduce themselves to voters
and to promote their views on issues and
here now is a look at some of the
candidates books and reply all Jeb Bush
catalogues his email correspondence
during his time as the Florida Governor
presidential candidate and former
neurosurgeon ben Carson argues that a
better understanding of the Constitution
is necessary to solve America's most
pressing issues in his latest book a
more perfect union former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton looks back on her
time serving in the Obama administration
in hard choices and in a time for truth
Texas senator Ted Cruz recounts his
journey from a Cuban immigrant son to
the US Senate and Ohio Governor John
Kasich calls for a return to what he
sees as traditional American values in
stand for something more presidential
hopefuls with books include Florida
Republican Senator Marco Rubio in
American Dreams he outlines his plans to
advance economic opportunity the winner
of the New Hampshire Democratic primary
independent senator Bernie Sanders
recently updated his 1997 autobiography
now titled outsider in the White House
to include his time in the Senate and
the launch of his presidential campaign
and businessman Donald Trump winner of
the New Hampshire Republican primary
outlines his political platform in
crippled America Gary Johnson is a
presidential candidate for the
Libertarian Party in seven principles of
good government he discusses his
political philosophy and his time as
governor of New Mexico book TV has
covered many of these candidates and you
can watch them on our web site book
tv.org
anyhow my
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the Palestine Center my name is Zane
Azam and I'm the executive director here
and welcome also to our online audience
before we start our program I just want
to bring to your attention the
exhibition that we've got that will be
actually starting next week so you
probably saw some of the items it's
called reaching across the world the
hand of Fatima and we will have the
opening reception for the exhibition on
Friday a week from today our our curator
Dagmar painter is putting it all
together and you can take a look outside
on your way out
today we're delighted to welcome back to
the palestine center dr. Steve Selita I
think most of you know that in 2014 his
offer of a tenured professorship in the
American Indian studies program of the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign was revoked by the
University's Board of Trustees the
purported reason was his public tweets
criticizing the Israeli government's
assault on Gaza that summer his firing
generated a huge public outcry with
thousands petitioning for his
reinstatement and more than 5,000
scholars pledging to boycott the
University of Illinois his case raises
important questions about academic
freedom about free speech on campus but
the strength of pro-israel influence in
many sectors of American society and
about the movement for justice in
Palestine in his book on civil rights
Palestine and the limits of academic
freedom which is the title of our talk
today dr. Selita combines personal
refract reflection and political
critique to provide an analysis of his
controversial firing he examines the
most important issues that affect both
higher education and social justice
activism
let me tell you a little bit about him
and his background
Steve Selita is the author of six books
including modern Arab American fiction a
reader's guide and Israel's dead soul
his articles tackle a number of subjects
including humor and resistance race and
American society Islamophobia anti-arab
racism colonialism identity indigenous
studies and a lot more he holds a PhD in
Native American Studies and in theory
and modernity from the University of
Oklahoma previously he was associate
professor at Virginia Tech during the
2015-2016 academic year dr. Selita is
serving as the AdWords side chair of
American Studies at the American
University of Beirut were delighted that
he's here today from Bader's copies of
dr. selita's book on civil rights will
be available for purchase after the
event we've asked them to talk for about
15 minutes 40 minutes sorry after which
we'll open the floor for discussion
those of you who are online can tweet
your questions to us at palestine center
please join me in welcoming professor
Steven salaita
[Applause]
okay hi can everybody hear me well okay
louder okay how is this okay well thank
you very much for for coming out this
this afternoon and and spending a little
bit of time with me I I especially want
to thank the the Palestine Center and
and Isaiah Nizam and and everybody who
helped Bob put the talk together I'm
gonna try not to be too long-winded
which is sometimes a problem for me so
we can have plenty of time for for
conversation and and questions and and
discussion I haven't given a public talk
in in quite some time and and I think
since I was last active on the circuit
of discussing you know academic freedom
and my firing and and you know the
suppression of speech and activism in
defense of Palestinian human rights a
lot has changed in in my own personal
circumstances so I've been in Beirut
since August it's it's been a very
interesting and rewarding experience
the lawsuit got settled but the
suppression of those who speak in
support of palestinian liberation
continues and in many ways at an
alarming rate we're seeing students
professors community activists in a
recent case a high school student being
punished for speaking against Israeli
human rights violations we've seen in
some instances recently folks being
criminalized for speech in favor of
Palestinians so the problem is ongoing
and one thing that I tried my best to do
ever since the firing put me into
something of a spotlight to speak about
the situation was
to highlight the reality that this isn't
an individual but an institutional
problem and it's going to require an
institutional response and the
institutional response isn't going to be
simple I think the advent and the
development and really the popularity of
BDS boycott divestment and sanctions you
know over the past ten years but it's
it's really picked up steam in the past
two or three years has led to the
vicious sort of response we have
billionaires like Haim Saban and Sheldon
Adelson pumping literally millions of
dollars into not only combating BDS but
really any kind of narrative that is
favorable to the freedom or in many
cases the mere existence of Palestinians
or Palestinians with a voice we see too
many university presidents and upper
administrators in the thrall of these
moneyed interests we're also seeing a
particular appropriation of a kind of
tender language of Student Wellness
that's being deployed on US campuses the
the language of comfort and safe space
anti bullying these sorts of things
being deployed by pro-israel students as
a way of conceptualizing pro-palestine
activists as somehow existing beyond the
pale and engaging in various forms of
unethical or inappropriate behavior the
Israeli government has devoted plenty of
time and resources to combating the
so-called problem of BDS and the
existence now of significant communities
on and off campus who are speaking about
Israeli war crimes and we're advocating
for the Liberation of Palestine and the
Palestinian people so the problem is
institutional I knew at the moment of my
firing that
I wasn't the first person in a khadeem
to have been punished in such a way I
also knew unfortunately that I wouldn't
be the last that's one element of
speaking about Palestine on and off
campus but I'm mostly interested in what
happens on campus you know given my
professional location in my recent
history that anybody who's interested in
this sort of work has to come to grips
with it's an ugly reality but it's a
reality nevertheless and the way I
always put it is is by suggesting to
people and and I kind of closed the book
on on this note with this bit of
unsolicited advice that when it comes to
speaking in favor of Palestinian dignity
and Palestinian human rights somebody's
going to be punished somebody is always
punished the moment that you are
prepared to be the perfect